the council will be able to agree a
general approach on railway safety the
agreement will send a clear message that
their creation of the single European
railway area is on the full track
meeting expectations of industry and
citizens so today I am very concerned
actually about safety and its railway
package concerning safety meaning that
the suggestion is that responsibility
for safety should be everyone's
responsible I think it will be a mistake
the no one will actually take that
responsible so that will I argue for
today if you look from the manufacturers
viewpoint there is no big interest of
manufacturers to do have individual
national certificates if another
possibility is to have 20 certificate
for whole Europe your tarot docket
permanent colony shalise suga be under
Stroup's that the presidency managed to
incorporate incorporate different
comments and remarks of various member
states in its proposal regarding those
balances and I believe we managed to
find the right balance between the
national and global and the European
railway agency I would like to stress
one more autopost Gilligan killer in row
straight a pot polarity and railway
industry is pursuing it also supported
the proposal of the presidency